here is how i set goals so that i can
actually hit them and this is coming
from some guy who is you know frankly
pretty lazy and um you know i don't
um i'm not like you like i'm not like oh
i need to lose weight i must have a 500
calorie deficit therefore it is done i
will now like you know track this thing
that always felt like too much work to
me but let me tell you what does work
for me
um
by the way the exact opposite it's less
work to do it that way because then you
don't think you just like do you just do
what you're supposed to do classic thing
that somebody who has discipline and
willpower says like oh it's easier to
just do it right the first time yeah we
know bro if we if we know that that's
true we just don't live life that way
like it's okay
you know i i speak from the
procrastinators perspective
[Music]
all right you want to tell us about this
game or what well first of all i think
we need to spice up the intro
i think the intro needs to be
like right now we're just casual with it
we just come on like it's just a
conversation and people love that they
love the authenticity but you know what
you know what works when you become a
cheese ball and you just start
performing and making a show and you
give a proper intro you do all the
things this is my first million the
podcast that has two future
trillionaires that come at you oh by the
way
did you see this guy who went on
linkedin and then quoted the manifest
cowboys thing
wait whoa what happened i tagged you in
it some guy was talk he's telling the
story
oh bro i'm going ham on linkedin right
now
like what do you mean like trying to get
pocket i told you i hired that content
remixer guy
brandon and so brandon's been amazing
what he does he just takes my old good
tweets he posts them on linkedin and
people on linkedin
bro it's a gun to a knife fight they're
like wow
incredible content this is wow
what a conversation this is stimulating
because you know linkedin is like the
most boring content farm generically
right so like i've been over here
fighting on twitter against like you
know [__] professional tweeters who
are researching eight hours a day and
like creating these like epic threads
and you know i just come off the dome
bro like you know i i i'm that painting
at the top of the sistine chapel i'm
just off the top
and
now i bring that to linkedin
and it's a whole new it's a habanero
pepper for them and so it's a ghost
pepper it's the last wing on hot ones
and they don't know what to do with it
and so this guy's been posting so i just
get to check the um
the notifications and i'll be like oh
[__] he posted that thing from like a
year ago that i said and people on
linkedin are loving it but today it's
getting popular
yeah i think i added like i don't know a
thousand followers this week or
something like that dude by the way i i
knew this woman named candice you maybe
knew her too and she was an entrepreneur
and she owned a bikini company and she
was like you know what i'm just gonna
start this in
2015-16-17 she goes i'm going to start
posting like stories about our bikini
business and like you know how things
are going and so it like like new
product updates whatever and it was all
like you know hot ladies and bikinis you
know like right
like what the algorithm
it went crazy it broke people's braid
and she eventually got banned and she
obviously did the right thing of like
making a public fuss about it like what
i'm just talking about my business
what's wrong with this this is
professional content i sell bikinis i've
got it so it worked awesomely for her
and so i think that if you have a
business that is like uh related to
something like you know like that you
could kill it on like it but anyway so
you're crushing it on linkedin right now
yeah so this guy yeah this guy thomas
angel give him a shout out he um
he posted he goes
it says quote i don't do business i
manifest hashtag mfm and then he goes uh
sprouts farmer's market was number one
on our vision board when we launched our
everything latte at altitude functional
beverages i guess that's his company
altitude functional beverages so he goes
after 13 months we're now in 10 stores
blah blah blah we're great we're great
we're great and he goes thank you to the
ogs hashtag manifest cowboys and then he
tagged us
and i totally forgot you had said that
on the last spot and i was like wow
that is incredible manifest cowboys is
one of your top five uh little creations
and like i just feel like we need to go
all in
on the only podcast featuring two
trillionaires the manifest cowboys
the men who never age
haven't seen a wrinkle in my life
same body fat as your milk two percent
like that's how we need to go and then
we say
hey itunes play that back 15 go back 15
seconds play that again
did you pick up that two percent
nonsense that's beautiful
again off the top i told you i'm good
early in the morning we just we moved
our podcast to an early morning
recording and i just have like an extra
10 percent juice early in the morning
where i'm a little crazy
yeah i just roll out of bed and these
are the thoughts in my head
yeah dude you're like a rapper right now
you keep rhyming i like this i saw this
hilarious clip of um it's actually my
favorite form of marketing
is you take a clip from something else
so you've seen this one where it's a bar
and they're what the whole bar is
watching something on a big screen and
it's like the the original clip was like
from the world cup and like the guy
scores a goal but something on there
yeah you just put whatever on there
right like i'll put like the milk road
the milk road like shows up in your
inbox like you know the email pops up
and then the crowd just goes crazy and
so i saw a version of that somebody did
it with joe rogan it's joe rogan talking
to somebody and he's like have you seen
this i thought the guy's like no he's
like pull that up and then they just
replace it with this tick tock of this
young chubby white boy rapping and he's
really horrible but it's hilarious and
he's like dancing and rapping at the
same time and joe's like god how do they
do it and like they show the reaction
but they've spliced it together
and uh i saw one of those and so that
just really you know made my morning
i spent so many hours in the morning and
at night just scrolling through
instagram and tic toc and just laughing
constantly at all these just young
people are so funny now i don't think
when i was younger and like that age
doing stuff like this
no one was this funny like the amount of
funny people is it's it's way higher now
me and my sister we said each other
maybe she says me like 25 tick tocks a
day i sent back maybe 10.
and like the caption on each one isn't
like it's not like
oh you got to watch this oh this is
really funny or uh
that's so true it's
every every like seven lines she's just
like
people are too good like
how would how are they so talented like
because tick tock is the greatest talent
show ever created it's america's
funniest home video every hour on the
hour right it's like
it is this giant talent show and when
you watch it you're like i am nothing
compared to these people
the dirt on their shoe
they scrape me off before they walk into
their house like you feel so dumb
um and i just like i can't i don't
understand how they come up with these
how they film them
like where the where the inspiration
comes from it's too good
it's so good and the subreddit the
fighter and the kid that you and i like
just like the commenters are so funny
it's like every
every top comic it's like one of the
best jokes done
by a comedian that i like
you know what i mean like it's
like that's how high caliber it is i
just and it's almost like the way that i
describe it it's like it doesn't matter
if you're into the outdoors or not when
you see a big mountain you're like oh
wow that's epic you know like you
appreciate the epicness that's how i
feel like when i watch tick-tock i'm
like i don't even like this thing that
they're talking about but how on earth
did someone come up with this and it's
just that over and over and over again
and i'm in awe i mean all constantly
yeah people talk about how uh these
things are a waste of time
uh i don't know what their tick tock
feed is like my tate tuck feed is
incredible it is the most entertainment
per second i've ever experienced in my
life it is
funny it is like insightful i'll learn
stuff all the time little life hacks how
stuff works uh watching a tick tock
about like you know how a farmer like
you know
farm squash i'm like oh i didn't know
that right like i'm just learning stuff
that i didn't even know i wanted to know
because i would never click the youtube
video but bro if i go on youtube now
it's like
you know you know when you go to a city
and they're like uh you know there's
like by the tourist destination they're
like oh you want to get on this horse
carriage you know big for a funny
picture and like you know it's a
romantic date and you gotta like do this
old slow uncomfortable thing because i
might as well you know i got to do
something different life's too good now
that's how i feel when i go on youtube
like i'm getting back on the horse
carriage after i've experienced like an
f1 car and i don't know how youtube's
gonna survive
dude speaking of like this type of stuff
speaking of like uh uh entertainment and
like doing epic [__] i'm reading this
book about this woman named ellsbeth
ellspeth beard that's an interesting
name and in 1979 or 1980 i think she was
22 years old and she just like says [__]
it i'm gonna ride my motorcycle around
the country or sorry around the world
around the globe so like you like get on
a ship and go to america right all
across america get on a ship on the
other side go to whichever continent is
on the other side of your office yeah is
this your pen name
dude i did it across america which is
soft that's soft like there's a
mcdonald's every 50 miles you know she
did it like in iran and [__] you know
what i mean like
like there's levels to this game and she
did it in 1979 and so like she was like
we couldn't even get maps but anyway i
was reading it and i was like
i'm such a [__] like why why don't we
live more do we do we need to live more
epic adventurous lives she did this
thing at age 22 and now she's like 65
she's still giving talks on about it and
making money because we are all so weak
and we refuse to do like these
interesting it's not that hard nowadays
to ride a motorcycle across the world
it's not that hard you take six months
you buy a 20 000 b w it ain't gonna
break you use your iphone it ain't hard
but i just a thought it was interesting
that she did this thing at age 22. it's
kind of like whenever i like see people
like um
whenever i see like the rolling stones
perform i'm like this motherfucker's 80
years old and he's playing a song that
he wrote when he was 18. that's
longevity that's good that and that's
kind of what she's doing so i'm like
amazed that you could do one thing at a
young age and live off of it forever and
b
we're soft man we got to do more epic
stuff like we're just sitting in our
houses all the time doing this lame
stuff all the time we gotta we gotta be
more adventurous right what would you do
i've always wanted to walk across
america so i would do that i've already
ridden my motorcycle across america i've
driven across america a bunch of times i
think i could drive my motorcycle across
what was genuinely hard so not like um
it sounds hard but what genuinely was
hard
i um
with with riding a motorcycle across the
country it wasn't just in general other
stuff you've done anything you've done
what's the actual thing that you've like
that's been really hard doing an iron
man that was like legitimately hard like
i felt pain i think it'd be fun like
ride a bicycle or something like that
across america and i think that would be
genuinely tough like physically and
emotionally tough i did an iron man and
that was like legitimately hard i felt
like i was in pain for almost the entire
time it sucked
dude so
uh ramon and suli there they texted me
ramon was like guys we gotta do this
iron man in hawaii an idiot
i'm signing us up
and like he caught me when i was in that
when i had that trillionaire two percent
body fat energy and i just
two words all caps i'm in
did you really say that he literally
didn't even know how to ride a bike no
he was typing his speech bubbles and i
just i just responded i go i go
ramon say no more and then he stopped
typing in the imessage
okay three hours he booked it he booked
it didn't it three hours pass
yeah he starts sending me like pdf
ticket reservations he starts sending me
stuff i'm like
and i now realize what i have done
and i realized
your boy's not as hard as he thinks
he's not as tough as he thinks
he's not as in as he thought he was in
and do you even know how to swim have
you ever swam before
i have a 15-foot pool and i can swim in
it but i've never it's like a one-mile
free like an ocean
freestyle swim
just to start the race
and so i go
and so i then i had to backtrack so i
just came quick i go
hey i've seen the first one but can't
wait for the second one like a what
iron man right that's what we're talking
about the movie
he goes no bro you're not getting out of
this
no
i am
and then he's that's i didn't have any
reason and then he's so then every day
he's been texting me like
hey here's this cool link to how to
train and i'm like i'm not opening that
link because if i open that link there's
no if i know what it's what it entails
there's no way i'm gonna do that so i
was guilty to do this by him and i
trained for six months and i did pretty
good i did all right and he got last and
you're very very fit and you're saying
it's hard if i trade it was the hardest
for a year i would not be as fit as you
were before you trained for your ironman
i would be the before photo
and so
it doesn't make sense and so then i just
told him i go
if i don't talk to you anymore i don't
have to do it
and so i'm just not responding to it and
we'll see if this just for the listener
so they know how stupid like it was like
the three stooges we went down there and
i trained i i i was a division athlete i
trained i did fine i was great but
they and i hired a coach i did
everything the right way these freaking
idiots who we went with they bought they
bought the bike the day before when they
were down there
and like then the night before you set
your bike up at the place and they leave
it there and silly and ramon were like
hey so how do we use those pedals with
that attached to your feet we bought
them how do we use them they were like
setting it up there and zuli this other
guy who we went with he did the swim he
did the entire thing in backstroke
because he didn't know how to swim with
his head underneath the water
and they assigned a kayaker lifeguard to
him because they were so afraid that he
was going to drown i swear to god
and but he finished oh he did it
of all the 9 000 people there i'm not
exaggerating they got
literally last place
last and so like 9 000.
and they were miserable and the next day
they're like
this is sick bro you won't do it again
it was the craziest [__] on earth these
guys are idiots they also asked me if i
was if i wanted to go climb mount
kilimanjaro with them
and i was like no no i'm out no i do not
want to do that yeah the problem is
they're like i don't know seven to ten
years older than us so they're like in a
midlife crisis and we're getting dragged
into their
midlife
fighting against father time uh you know
thing and now we are doing these things
as well yo so actually this is a topic i
wanted to talk about which is
how to
set goals i think you had something on
your thing about i wrote something about
that
yeah so let's talk about this so i don't
know what you wanted to do but i had
this idea of
what is your approach to setting and
hitting goals is that what you were
going to say yeah well let me like go on
a little rant here so i've been doing
this thing called intro you know that
intro thing like you just like talk to
people and it's actually really fun
that's why i do i do it from friday at 5
00 p.m to 7 p.m two hours so if they
just turned off the money you'd do it
because it's so fun
no i am doing it because it's fun and i
get paid uh 2 000 an hour obscene
amounts of money
yeah so both it is it is it's fun money
envelope money um
and i've been doing this and a question
that i ask people constantly and they
never rarely have answers to and they
act like i'm like profound for asking
this i'm like dude this is like table
stakes which is what does success look
like in five years like specifically
like if this is a money thing like how
much money do you want how much revenue
how many users whatever and what i've
learned and then i've been working with
some family members and they're like
want to get their finances in order and
i'm like all right well how much do you
spend every month
how much do you want to spend every
month and then let's work back for how
much income you think you need
and i think the vast majority of people
they don't write [__] down and so i did
this one intro call with this guy and i
was like hey so here's this app that i
used for a long time it's called my
weekly budget you just every time you
spend a cent just write it down and just
do it for uh four weeks and then just
look back at how much you spend and like
oh i never thought about that and he
messaged me and he goes i've been
writing this down for like two weeks i
had no idea i was spending this and that
and this i've been saving thousands of
dollars now that i know and i do the
same thing with weight loss i say i want
to weigh this much weight therefore i
have to burn i can only eat 2100
calories and i'm just gonna write down
whatever i eat um
just writing things down both goals as
well as like the things that you're
doing so you kind of like have an idea
is the easiest way to get to where you
want to go without really changing a
significant amount of your behavior you
have you ever noticed that
i have noticed that yes and i do that i
think i think a lot of people think they
do that but let me go into
a little more detail on
some some stuff i do that i think is
maybe a little bit different all right
so i'm going to give you a couple bullet
points here is how i set goals so that i
can actually hit them and this is coming
from some guy who is you know frankly
pretty lazy and um you know i don't
um i'm not like you like i'm not like oh
i need to lose weight i must have a 500
calorie deficit therefore it is done i
will now like you know track this thing
that always felt like too much work to
me but let me tell you what does work
for me
um
by the way we're seeing the exact
opposite it's less work to do it that
way because then you don't think you
just like do you just do what you're
supposed to do classic thing that
somebody who has discipline and
willpower says like oh it's easier to
just do it right the first time yeah we
know bro if we and we know that that's
true we just don't live life that way
like it's okay you know i i speak from
the procrastinators perspective all
right so
here are some things that i do that do
work for me
first is
you tell me if you do this or not
i set picture goals or movie scene goals
not just written goals so for example
uh sometimes it's hard for me to figure
out like let's say it's a financial goal
okay how much money do i want and when
and then i kind of like i'll pick a
number is that too high is that too low
and i got to make it real in some way so
sometimes what i'll do is if it's a
number goal
i'll do the math to add it up i'll be
like okay here's how i want to live i
want to spend this this this and this
what does that actually come out to and
i'll go bottoms up to create the goal or
i'll just simplify it i'll be like i
don't know numbers and logic is a little
too hard to understand i'll go on zillow
and i'll just find the picture of the
house i want i'll be like this this is
my goal and i can just look at that
picture of that house and it has a whole
feeling and a whole like set of
assumptions that if i was living in that
house like life is pretty good that is
my motivating goal like i'm more
motivated by a picture or a little movie
scene in my head
than i am by
just this like kind of written text that
it requires my brain to do a bunch of
like
work to try to like make life out of
this
text yeah i do it yeah i guess i just
described a vision board okay cool so
yeah that's the first thing pinterest
yeah great idea
yeah
all right it's like an uber but
okay let's keep going
second thing i do
floor goals and ceiling goals so i don't
set one goal i set a range the floor
goal that i'll set for any project is
like all right at a minimum this is like
the minimum that it would take for it to
feel like a win
and so i just would write that down i'll
be like all right this is the minimum
goal and beca and
what was happening was normally i was
writing a goal
then i'd be like kind of beating myself
up like i'm not ambitious enough so i
need to set up more audacious goals so i
set a bigger or bigger bigger hole
and then i would like you know
inevitably like sort of under deliver on
that and now i'd have to like
basically i'd either be disappointed
because i didn't reach my like super
ambitious goal but still clearly a good
thing happened
or i would have my super ambitious goal
and secretly in my head i'd have like my
backup goal that like i wouldn't tell
anybody because it wasn't so cool but
like i knew logically that that was good
so then i just started writing it down
here's the floor here's the ceiling
ceiling is the the f yeah like what
would make me say yeah that really
worked out um and so like
uh i'll give you an example i'll give
you an example after this but all right
floor in a ceiling goal that's the next
one do you do anything like that like a
range
no but that's a good idea i just no i
just like put the
maybe i kind of do i say here's what i
think will happen but then i say in the
best case scenario i think this might
happen but i'm not expecting that
right that's how i started this podcast
i was like the floor goal is if i just
invite a bunch of cool guests on well
i'll probably like if i do one of these
a week 52 guests let's say half of them
are cool let's say half of those cool
people become kind of like buddies or
friends or you know we like each other
cool so i'll make like maybe 12 15
new friends that are like kind of heavy
hitters enough where i could invite them
on a podcast i was like that's a win
that alone is a win it's enough to like
do this do this podcast for for you know
once a week and so that was my floor
goal my ceiling goal was well what if
people actually listen to this wouldn't
that be sweet if people would you know
on their commutes and they would listen
to this and and you know
we'd have this big audience of people
who like listen and trust us that would
be amazing right
i use that methodology for risk taking
so
i say should i quit my job and start
this company well the worst case
scenario is that it's going to take me
six months to find a new job therefore
i'll have six months of savings lined up
and if i just so happen to build a
successful company that's gravy that's
awesome but this but i just basically
i'm taking the risk that i'm gonna i
just i'm assuming that i'm gonna find a
new job and have six months of savings
great that's my baseline i'm fine with
that
so floor and ceiling that's the second
part
um
okay goals and anti-goals so i stole
this from andrew wilkinson who stole it
from somebody else probably but
it's really easy
to
set a goal
and not acknowledge some of the common
trappings you could get even if you
accomplish your goal simple example
in college my buddy dated this girl her
dad was like a partner at a big
consulting firm and he was a partner he
guy would make you know a million two
million dollars a year probably he was
he made it to the top of his like
top of that ladder
but also he was you know
oh every single week he would fly out
monday through thursday he would come
back friday be there friday saturday
sunday he would leave again sunday night
and he was just gone for like half of
her life growing up and so that's an
example of achieving your goal but maybe
hitting an anti-goal as well which was
he probably didn't plan and set out to
say i don't want to see my family you
know my kid growing up for the first 18
years life i'm only gonna be there half
the time but it just kind of came as a
byproduct of trying to hit their goal so
now i set out specific anti-goals like
oh yeah i want to do this podcast but i
don't want it to feel like a bunch of
work every week right like i'm not
trying to make this my job i want this
to be a fun hobby right and so
an anti-goal might be all of a sudden
i'm drowning in work trying to edit this
thing and upload the thumbnail and write
the show notes and do all this stuff
that would be an anti-goal if the after
pod recording took five hours a week or
uh you know ten hours a week to go to
produce it and so by identifying the
anti-gold up front you can make a game
plan that that solves it do you do that
i do it a little bit differently i don't
call it an anti-gold no i say here's
what here's the price i'm willing to pay
to achieve the thing i want to achieve
so for example when i was i said um when
i'm gonna start this company the hustle
i told my wife i go when we were dating
i go just so you know the business is
going to come first for the next handful
of years because then when we get
married and have kids i'll have more
time for that but like right now
business is first and i'm going to give
up vacations i'm going to give up the
price i'm willing to pay is we're just
not going to have that much time
together unless if the business gets in
the way right
baby tell me again uh who's number one
on my priority list
yes that's right say it again say it
again again
[Music]
say it again yeah tell me it's
valentine's day who's my date the hustle
that's right that's right you got it you
got it you understand
to confirm you got a double opt into
this [__]
so i always say here's the thing i'm
willing to get i'm this this is the
price i'm paying you know what i'm
saying you want to look good
the price you gotta yeah you want to
look good in the nude the price you got
to pay is you've got to eat this crap
chicken and like not have fun there you
know you got to pay a price
right
um i like that all right the next one in
your face daily so now we're on number
four we painted the picture that's kind
of the mood board the movie scene the
floor and ceiling method the goal and
anti-gold method and now in your face
daily this is one where i think a lot of
people make a mistake they write down
the goal at the moment they're motivated
and inspired and they they read that
book they watched that video you know
they got their pen and paper out they
write it down then they close the book
and then they just go back onto
autopilot for the next like 17 days
and they can't even revisit their they
don't revisit their goal
so my big thing is i need to see it
daily right the goal is like the barista
you know if i'm going to get coffee
before work every day i'm going to see
this face i'm going to see my goals face
every single day and so i will set this
up in slack i will set up i'll just use
the remind
function i'll say remind me every day
that my goal this week is for milk road
to add this many subscribers or to go
viral with one post on twitter or to you
know
to chase down that investment that i'm
really bullish about and make sure we
get in this round and i will set that
reminder so that it pops up every single
day and it's only me who sees that but
now i do that with my team
at the end of every you know either
daily or weekly i will repost the goals
that we had for the week and just be
like you know
here it is make sure you keep this top
of mind or as my next my next method is
the tip of your tongue test which is
[Music]
if you can't say what you want
if it's not at the tip of your tongue
what you're going for
you're not clear enough about it and
like you are not giving yourself the
best chance to succeed because you can't
articulate your goal at the tip of your
tongue ben can i can i pick on you for a
second ben are you there i know he's
like at the beach so he may not have the
best uh audio video
i i got kicked out of my last spot i can
i can try
okay try ben with your podcast how to
take over the world what is the goal the
goal is to be a top 100 pod
cast overall uh in in apple podcast
ratings
okay sounds good sam critique that real
quick he's missing one critical element
do you know what it is
probably the input
the input meaning what
uh like
you i think for a goal setting it's
probably a little bit easier to be input
oriented so like what you're willing
like i'm gonna do x i'm gonna do x
you know because you can't exactly
control the output so like it'd be more
input oriented i would also probably say
if for podcasts i would put a download
number on it but i don't know what do
you think right oh or a time box right
like by winning oh a time box
do you have 10 years to do this or one
year to do this that's a critical
element to a goal is to be it
it should be pass fail like it should be
easy to figure out did this happen or
not and if you don't have a time box you
can't you can't ever judge it right sean
do you have your do you have your
computer open yeah
go to my twitter handle and what's my
bio say
i have made this for the past uh
month or two and it's been working
wonderfully and it's exactly what you're
talking about oh perfect you go i own
the hustle sold it to hubspot i tweet
about this i do the podcast and then he
said
losing another five pounds this month
parenthesis august
yes i always whatever the the goal is i
put it up there in twitter so i see it
every day and the thing that you didn't
mention that i love doing is i love
shaming myself i love shame i think
shame and rage are the two best fuel
to like get something done that people
never talk about i i like i still do
things
to make aaron coyne my eighth grade
girlfriend angry like i'm still in my
head i'm like what's gonna prove her
wrong you know what i mean
like how am i gonna win and like prove
that she was wrong for breaking up with
me so i think rage is awesome but i
think like shaming yourself or like
guilting yourself or you put it publicly
and you have to do it the other thing
that i do constantly that works
wonderfully is you have to like set
appointments or put something on the
table so for example i i have these a
couple bad tattoos i want to get fixed
and i've been wanting to do i've been so
lazy you just you got to make the
appointment you make the appointment
it's like [__] i can't bail i already
put down money on this thing like i have
to do this you know what i mean and i
think that those things really really
help
yeah like my iron man competition coming
up but um
shame and rage that's a pretty good i
mean my first million's a good name
shaymin rage would have been a great
name for this podcast dude shaymin rage
is such a good fuel i don't know like
people say like you don't be angry i'm
like no [__] that anger i love anger i
love anger anger gives me so much
goodness like i i'm still like what is
the phrase chips on shoulders put chips
in pockets i love anger anger is such a
good
a a good uh emotion to drive you
i used to do that i used to i used to
have a thing that i've taken off this
list which was use your own psychology
against you
so it'd be like oh if i state publicly
what i'm gonna do then i feel the
pressure to go ahead and do it or like
yeah if i use kind of insecurity or
anger that could be like a fantastic
fuel for accomplishing my goals uh but i
don't i personally don't do that anymore
because it makes the process of doing
the thing
kind of unpleasant uh it is effective
for hitting the goal but well that's
because you have this really big problem
you've got a huge problem you know what
your problem is i'm too very emotionally
stable and happy yeah you've got that's
a really big issue in your life is
you're just too emotionally stable
um so
you know like i'm sorry that your
parents were wonderful to you but that's
just the price you have to pay
you know what i mean
yeah sam goes around to his house just
like shaving half an inch off every
table just trying to get it to have a
little bit of instability in it he's
like it's better
i want the plates to slide baby yeah you
know i had the advantage of you know
having a problematic childhood you you
you you were disadvantaged by having a
perfect little life
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients whole history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a test from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
all right i'm gonna finish my goal thing
real quick i got three more all right
last three the most important three are
uh i don't move unless i actually
believe that it's gonna happen yeah so a
lot of people will say and i would say
ben i i i you don't have to come back go
on but
people will say things like ben just
said and i would say at least half the
time if they are honest with themselves
i want to be a top 100 podcast in the
world by you know by you know in 12
months
if i said what do you what do you think
are the odds that that's gonna happen
they'll be like well
it is you know hard and it is risky you
know
and they'll sort of like
if it comes down to it their belief that
it's actually going to happen is quite
low
and i don't let myself move unless i
actually believe that it's gonna happen
because there's this like
there's a virtuous and vicious cycle
belief drives action if i really believe
that some shit's gonna work if i really
believe that this person's gonna say yes
and buy my product i will pick up the
phone immediately and call them
it's only when i don't believe they're
gonna buy my product that i some like
well i'll call them after i finish this
powerpoint day i'm gonna actually you
know friday is not a good day to call
because of this and
hold on let me just go clean my room
real quick you know because that's you
know i just want to get that done i'm
going to be a better head space like
it's your belief that drives the level
of action you're going to take like
massive belief equals massive action
massive action equals a good result and
a good result reinforces the belief this
is also what happens to people who
become have a lack of confidence they
don't believe therefore they take timid
action timid action creates shitty
results and that just reinforces to them
they're like see
i knew it wasn't like i kind of knew it
wasn't i knew it was gonna be too hard i
knew any of this wasn't like the odds
were against us and then it just happens
again and again so i don't move until i
i work myself into a spot where my
belief is super high
um
last two
baby goals or giggle steps so i've kind
of learned that like if you have a big
goal
you got to set a baby goal or a giggle
step a giggle step is a step
is that a trademark giggle step and just
a tip are your two
i met this woman and she she created
this uh phrase she was like hey you know
that book uh atomic habits by james
clear i was like yeah yeah she's like
it's it's all right and i was like oh
you mean like the best-selling book
that's like yeah i sold like three
million copies this year like one of the
greatest self-help books
you know in the last decade in terms of
for sale she's like yeah it's okay but
it's missing the most important thing i
was like what is it she goes
he's he got it kind of right that you
need to set like a simple first step
but it's even his is way too hard like
if you want to set a habit to floss your
teeth every day
you actually want to start with
something so simple it would make you
giggle because it's so not a goal that
it's achievable and you'll actually do
it and she's like so all you would do if
you wanted to floss your teeth every day
is literally put one piece of floss next
to your bathroom and like a next to your
sink and just floss a single tooth and
then put it down and walk away
it's like oh what's that gonna do with a
single tooth and it's like it'll
literally make you laugh it takes away a
lot of the fear and the built up
like scariness of going down this
endeavor who's this who's this lady
uh i hate that i forgot her name now um
but yeah i met her i think it betsy
betsy something i gotta find her last
name i don't remember last night that
sounds made up so far and it also might
not be your first name and i might be
the worst person in the world but like
giggle steps is good um see if you can
google that pull up her pull up her full
name i've only met her twice
um
okay last one is uh
last one is you got to revise up or
abort down so i think what a lot of
people do is as things get hard they
start to compromise the goal and they'll
start revising it down down down down
down to the point where it's not even
motivating anymore it's like you sort of
took the edge off the goal and yeah now
you kind of don't fail but you also
don't really succeed and so my rule is i
either revise up meaning i oh shoot i
think this could be even bigger right
this podcast we've revised up it's now
bigger than i thought it could be and so
now i've revised up okay
it can actually be
you know x millions of listeners every
month
um
hell we're already at you know one point
something 1.3 1.5 something like that
million per month why can't this be by
the way last month last month we were at
one point seven i think
yeah exactly so that's bigger than i
would have guessed right one if one was
my original goal i'm revising up now or
i'll just abort down i'll say you know
what
this isn't gonna that [__] that that
that's a weird word to use to describe
this
well
you know eject maybe is the better way
to say it i will i will just eject out
of uh you know the plane if i feel like
you know what now that we have given it
every throw and everything we've got at
this
and we've learned new things we have new
information that tells us that this is
this isn't gonna work rather than
compromising down and getting stuck on
something we're not even really excited
about if we're no longer excited about
it i'll just i'll change the goal
completely or i'll leave the goal aside
i'll just go do something else
because
um the new information has kind of shown
me
something to it's just a check to say
don't just continuously dial it down
because that's very
tempting to do and it's very easy to
slip into mediocrity so kind of by
forcing myself with something harsh
which is
all right would i just quit this
it's like so harsh that it forces me to
like no stick with the real goal and
find a way to make it happen or
change you know based on what your new
understanding of reality change this
completely don't just like take it down
a notch and another notch and another
not to another and now it's all of a
sudden not even that special to be good
so those are those are my how to hit
goals those are those are things i do to
hit goals i remember years ago you when
we were just kind of trying to we were
coming up trying to make it happen
you said that you go i think six million
dollars is the number i need to feel
financially like secure or i don't
remember what we're like stable or like
that i need to never work again free
did that goal change as you got older
were you right or wrong about that goal
um i think i was right but i
was wrong in one key aspect and actually
i said it on the podcast early on and
our friend narendra dmb and he was like
uh you're wrong six won't be like six is
not enough for you
and i was like well i don't know i like
i do the math he's like it's not enough
like you know first of all
uh maybe your target return of what you
think you're gonna make on that six you
know as you're because the idea is if
you have a certain amount of money
invested
what can you it is going to earn you
know it's going to compound at some rate
five percent seven percent a year
whatever it is
um could you live off of that compound
interest
rather than and the principle would
never go down you would never have to
withdraw lower than the principal so you
would you'd be financially free you
don't need new net income coming in
because the money you have is working
for your money now and you don't have to
go work for your money and you thought
that was six
i thought it was six because i've done
some conversations okay
um
now i think the number is like the real
number is probably closer to 10 or 11
and um
the aspirational number is like 25 and
up because then it's like oh it's not
even close at that point so the reason
why i'm bringing that up is the
interesting thing about goals is i used
to think if i if i achieve this thing
whether it's financial or body or
whatever that like i'm going to be
changed and i realized that pretty much
across the board every goal that i
achieve i'm like oh this was not as cool
as i thought i'm going to create a
harder one and
at first i was bummed but now i'm like
oh no that's not like because it's just
the chase like i'm born to hunt you know
what i mean like i have to chase a goal
and i have to accept that when i hit my
goal it's not going to change much
it's just going to be a cool benchmark
to go to the next one and so with goals
setting lately over the last couple
years i've been like oh but just know
that this isn't going to change anything
but it will be exciting to
chase after it and so that's what that's
an interesting thing that i've learned a
little bit with as i've gotten older
with goals
yeah and typically with financial goals
your lifestyle creeps up so like
before when i did the let's say 6
million number i was like all right 6
million if i earn five percent if i'm
getting five percent let's say they i
think the s p like kind of
average you know uh return is eight
percent or something like that i was
like okay let's say i can get five um
what would be you know that's 300k a
year cool at the time i think i was
spending under 200k a year and my burn i
was like ah that's good and i have like
you know 30 buffer
well now i spend i think more than that
and so because lifestyle creeps up it's
like you know i started to
pay for more stuff i started to buy more
things i started to travel a little bit
differently started to do all the things
that people do and now you didn't travel
differently you don't you just don't
travel
but when i do i drive a little bit
differently um the the point is the
lifestyle creeps up and so
um i think that's the thing you have to
do if you're
if you're not
trying to be really disciplined in your
lifestyle which i'm not i think life is
to be enjoyed and i want to enjoy it to
the fullest extent i know
and so as i learn new things new ways to
enjoy i want to do those things and not
feel limited by money um i think you got
to account for that you got to like over
buffer
are you looking to buy a house now
i'm looking at either buying or renting
a new house yeah
dude renting's so awesome i've been
loving renting man don't buy me too yeah
it's it's it's sick
the only downside with renting is just
like sometimes you don't there's not
enough inventory for like uh that is a
big one when you're in the burbs but
like if you're patient you could just
you can find it um and right now uh the
market seems to be at least where i'm at
in california and bay area the market
seems to be moving where
everything's getting marked down so
everything's down 20 30 percent
um except for stubborn sellers who
haven't realized yet that they need to
mark down and then even those aren't
getting offers and then they're pulling
their thing off the market because
they're like okay it's not selling now
this just looks bad and they're like
switching to okay we'll rent this or
we'll just stay in it or whatever like
the market is very quick
quickly turning here um to like a
buyer's market is what i'm kind of
saying
all right i have something interesting
to to share with you have you heard of
this company called
woot w-o-o-t of course yeah was like um
an internet staple og staple it was one
of the cool websites where it was like
you'd go and there was a daily deals
like buy this tv for like 22 or
something
so ethan brooks at the hustle kind of
told me about it but i had read about it
for a bit because the founder interests
me his he's this guy named matt rutledge
and woot was like like you said one of
the original like daily deal sites and
it was acquired by amazon and the story
is really interesting i remember reading
this a couple years ago so matt rutledge
is this guy from dallas and he flies up
to uh seattle to meet with bezos like
you know right when it closes and they
get a sunday breakfast and they're like
rutledge he wrote he's like bezos had
like a weird energy this whole time but
whatever i'm sitting in this meal and i
finally just say so jeff why did you buy
woot
and jeff like um had just ordered
breakfast and they have the meals in
front of them and he looks down at the
meal then he looks at matt and like 15
seconds passes and matt's like should i
just like ask him if he wants to like
move on and we just like skip this
and jeff looks down at his meal again
and then looks back up at rutledge and
he goes
you see um you're the octopus that i'm
having for breakfast right now because
jeff had just ordered like eggs and
octopus for some reason like a weird ass
breakfast
and he goes
when i look at the menu you're the thing
that i just don't understand basically
he had never ordered octopus for
breakfast before and he's like this is
weird i'm gonna order it i've never seen
it before i don't get it i'm gonna order
it you are the thing that i've never had
and i must have
for breakfast the octopus
and that's why he said he bought this
guy's company it is like
dude you're [__] insane like he
didn't think about it like like my
takeaway was rutledge was not like oh
fake story that is a fake story you
either just made that up or no i read it
in an article those were quotes
that is true those are direct questions
hilarious to be that is too hilarious to
be real
the exact quotes incredible this is this
is i'm going to read it verbatim from
the article and this is matt
in rutledge saying telling the reporter
you're the octopus that i'm having for
breakfast when i look at the menu you're
the thing that i just don't understand
the thing i've never had i must have
breakfast octopus
and he just any and that was like like a
20 seconds pause for him to say that
like just like this [__] weirdo like
you know like star trek type of guy
and uh as you'd expect as one would
expect from
what there have been many great stories
on this podcast many great stories
thousands of great stories i might say
this was the greatest story i've ever
heard on this podcast first of all you
told it great i didn't know where you
were going with this
the breakfast the looking down the
looking up the 15 seconds
and then that line is all time
weirdo
that is so weird of a thing what do you
expect
what do you expect i was actually i did
a podcast with someone and they asked me
about my successful friends and like
what do they all have in common i was
like well they all like work hard they
all like are smart but they're all
[__] weird they're all weird and like
everyone i know who's successful is
pretty [__] weird so do you know that
would say that line by the way that's
not that online no one no one but that
guy's like bezos is like the weirdest of
the weird maybe more
yeah like i've heard him say like yeah
like your business is one google away
from me destroying you like he says
stuff like that but this guy says i must
have the breakfast octopus but this
company woo it's really interesting
because it's basically just a daily deal
site whatever and like matt is like he
said amazon ruined it as you'd expect
and like but they did all this funny
stuff like they would sell a daily deal
and the deals that they didn't sell they
would create this feature called the bag
of crap which is a a a thing that like
users would just buy blindly and in the
faq it says like well if you don't like
it just list it on ebay but we don't
take refunds and um
anyway he leaves and he starts another
thing and he calls it the me a mediocre
corporation that's originally what it's
called and the uh
and the underlying premise is that we're
building a store that you don't need to
buy anything to have fun so like their
copy is really really good and he
basically said in an article he was like
um i want everyone's expectations to be
incredibly low with this business so
that's why we called it a mediocre
corporation and it's pretty hilarious
and i was reading their copy so now a
mediocre corporation they basically own
like eight different websites so
um and they're all like daily deal sites
and all of them have like 350 to 2
million
uh 2 million visits a month so i bet you
there it's actually a pretty substantial
business and if you read the copy it's
beautiful it's wonderful it's a
wonderful copy and i was thinking about
this the
basically as i've sold my company to a
big company i've realized that basically
for the longest time i thought basically
the only thing that a startup has that's
better than a big company and why a
startup can win is like focus we could
focus harder on stuff and we can move
faster so we can move fast and have more
focus and then i started reading about
this guy and i started thinking about
like the hustle like what made it
interesting and the second and the third
thing that i've added is that basically
be because there's less bureaucracy you
can have more soul you can do more funny
interesting stuff and the reason you can
is basically the founder comes up with
something says like we're just going to
do it whereas at a big company there's
like middle management and they're like
i don't want to lose my job so i'm not
taking this risk i'm not going to pitch
the bag of crap like feature even though
that's hilarious and users love it i
ain't pitching it i'm gonna i'm not
gonna do it and i'll give you a good
example so i love appsumo appsumo was
started by my friend noah kagan and uh
neville uh maduro is my good my best
friend and he like uh helped run it and
it was a daily deal site as well listen
to this copy so they ran a deal one time
where you could purchase like fonts i
don't know how you buy fonts but that
was the thing listen to the opening uh
paragraph from the daily email that he
sent out neville wrote this if the names
lucanda sands unico unicode or cor curry
or new don't mean anything to you go
ahead and close this message you see my
friend today we're reaching out to the
community of people known as font [__]
you know who you are
if your knees go weak when i whisper
garamond you might be one you might be
one of them
and i read this i remember this years
ago before i met neville and i was like
this is this is beauty this is beautiful
this turns off the people you want to be
turned off and it gets you know the
people who you want it and i was just
like in my head i'm like dude you're
writing about having sex with this font
that is so funny that is awesome you are
making the most boring topic really cool
and you cannot do that at a big company
it's incredibly hard and it's not hard
because the company's bad or good it's
just that's the rules of the game and
it's just like you're playing you know
the game on hard mode if you're trying
to like make
a big company cute
and i was just thinking this is just
this company woo it's just such a
perfect example you should go to some of
their websites they're they're uh
they're the mediocre corporation they
own casemates uh mediocrity that's one
of their things they own the site called
meh.com side deal morning save and it's
just deals and i thought it was
interesting and the copy is hilarious
and this is and i've been thinking about
businesses that you can build which you
are building and i did where it's just
like one or two people can kind of be
the taste makers and that can scale and
be leveraged really nicely kind of like
a daily email you know what i mean but
as you get bigger
you can't be able to do it all it's
going to get worse and worse and i think
that's just what's going to happen
yeah totally by the way their domain is
mediocre.com which is an amazing domain
to have uh this is such a cool story i
love that and i love that that email by
neville that's uh amazing copy the um i
think it's so true personality
personalities you said soul i would say
personality because it's called
personality interact with
it is such a differentiator in life in
all aspects of life but it it also works
in business people go into business
assuming you have to play some role you
have to like put on this suit and tie
and be some character
and all you're doing is simply blending
in with every other suit and tie that
exists out there and so they'll like i
see this all the time founders will try
to play the same game as the companies
they admire the big companies the
successful companies they assume because
they're successful
that i need to act like them if i too
want to be successful what they forget
was that before they were successful
early on the way they got successful was
through having personality having a
point of view having some edges to them
and those edges they keep some people
away because it's too rough for them
it's not what they wanted and for other
people they're like wow this is the
handle i need to grab onto because i
love this and so you know before apple
was apple
they were you know the home brew they
were at the homebrew computer club right
they were basically they had the two
advantages you talked about you said
focus i call it freakishly obsessive and
i use that word specifically because
they are obsessed with that some topic
whatever it is it could be raspberry
pies it could be blockchains it could be
whatever they're usually obsessed with
something that's not mainstream
because it's not that fun to be obsessed
with something that's already totally
mainstream there's not much joy in that
for this person and the second is that
they're freakishly obsessed which is not
only just an extreme form of obsession
but they're they're willing to go to a
length that other people wouldn't and
they're willing to like the topic is
usually niche and weird um so you know
fonts is a good example of one of one um
of things like that then the other part
that you mentioned which is personality
it just gets squashed out of a big
company because imagine if the at the
beginning when you're one or two people
the personality of the company is
basically the personality of the founder
or founders and it's typically like a
room of people and they're like
one-upping each other it's like haha
that's funny like all right but check
this out what if we even went even
harder like you know like you can have
that like vibe because you're
incentivized to do that you want to grow
you want to do interesting stuff
totally you're not incentivized once the
company gets bigger
imagine a room imagine a room of of one
person okay it's just that per whatever
that person thinks it's normal to them
you get two people two co-founders maybe
they're both a little bit weird and so
they riff off each other it gets going
now you add the third wheel even if that
third wheel was totally vanilla they're
a total normal person they're now
outnumbered
so they join the thing and they're like
all right
i guess that's how we get down here
right you had a phrase you go you need
to let your freak flag fly if you're
gonna work here and so you whoever came
in you indoctrinated them into your
weird culture to do weird [__] and do
cool [__] and that was normal there so
the third person comes in even if
they're vanilla all of a sudden they
become flavored too the fourth person
comes in same thing but at some point
the next like i don't know where it is
15 20 30 40 50 people somewhere in that
range i would say between 15 and 50
people
the person who gets hired typically will
spend most of their time and not with
the founders anymore
and so now they're now one vanilla
person is spending time with a bunch of
other vanilla people and they're hiring
other people who have a greater and
greater percentage of vanilla right it
starts with they need to be 25 30
because hey we need to be serious and
get stuff done around here then you
start hiring 50 vanilla and by the time
you get to 50 or 100 people you're
hiring a hundred percent vanilla people
and those people now when they someone
says a weird idea it's crickets in the
room it's risks come first there's
reasons why not rather than why we would
it's oh yeah that has this one extreme
strength but it might have some other
extreme weaknesses so don't take the
risk that's gonna offend certain people
or that's gonna like cannibalize this
thing or that thing or yeah it's just
like [__] excuses right what will
they say what will they think and so
what will they say well really what it
comes down to
it comes down to i've got a good gig
i don't want to [__] it up
uh let's not let's not rattle this you
know i don't want to shake this up yeah
exactly and i'm not comfortable shaking
it up because i don't know that that's
what we do here because a lot of time
has passed i don't hang out with the
people who that are like totally high
conviction of being weird
and um
and yeah like i i have some i have more
to lose than i have to gain by doing
this because when i say this idea i
don't get respect in the room i get sort
of like strange glances and nervous
laughter and then you know somebody
tells me why my idea is a bad idea so i
learn to just keep that [__] piped down
my freak flag is now
you know buried at the bottom of my
trunk and it you know it's folded up and
it's in its case and so that's what
happens at the at the end of these
companies now some companies fight that
off so for example this is why i think a
lot of people like founder-led companies
because they keep that soul they have
one person in the company who has a
gravitas
so like i think i think this happened at
uh tesla and it happened at elon's
companies he is so publicly weird and
big thinking and out there and willing
to just go with it that he kind of sets
the tone even if you don't on a day to
day ever have meetings with elon or work
with him or you don't get the culture
from him inside the company you get it
from seeing what he does on twitter so
he kind of did you see his new butthole
feature
yeah exactly and so
now if you're at tesla you're like okay
the boss's boss's boss's boss likes that
weird [__] and it gets a bunch of play
on twitter and we've seen five things
pay off by going overboard like
does the cyber truck window really need
to be bulletproof
no but elon would think that's [__]
cool so we're gonna do it and i know
elon thinks it's gonna be cool because
he lets the flag fly on twitter and so i
see it even though i don't interact with
them day-to-day so that's one way to
scale that personality is to have a such
a strong personality and do it on blast
another version i remember when i was at
dude but he's got to put up with so much
[__] for that and it's actually to be in
his position i've been in this position
and i've like weakened out a bunch of
times where i'm like oh fine i'll let
you guys get your way this time like you
know like you're gonna quit if i don't
give it to this fine i'll let you have
it this time and in my head i'm like but
this is the wrong decision but i'm only
making i'm only agreeing to go with this
even though i don't like it because like
i don't want them to quit and like i
just don't want this headache right now
whereas he's the type of guy because
he's like you know like on the spectrum
he's like no i don't like pick up on
this social cue like we are not doing it
like we're this is fine i'm okay being
uncomfortable here you know what i'm
saying
and that's that's how i'm inspired by
him a little bit the belief in himself
and also just the lack of self-awareness
uh is is important there right you can't
be like us you can't be a self-werewolf
and just have too much self-awareness
like you have to have a little bit of
like you know
you know you don't give a [__] in your
system in order to do this well
at twitch one thing happened i remember
that i was like
super super proud to like be there
working there at the time i was like
because i gave it a lot of [__] you know
i just do the sort of like
the stereotypical startup guy thing
where you're like
startup cool big company dumb big
company's slow big company boring big
company no risk big company no
innovation right like it's the startup
caveman who's just like you know like um
you know small startup good even though
small startup is like failing and has no
money and like no users no no impact no
nothing it's like still in our head
there's like something to be really
proud of there
but sometimes at these companies some
really cool [__] happens and what i
remember one was
they released this campaign for prime
day so twitch gets bought by amazon
amazon wants all of the amazon companies
to really push prime day it's like it's
basically its own black friday that they
created where it's like yo here's an
excuse to go spend a bunch of money that
you otherwise weren't gonna spend and
prime day is huge for for amazon so they
you know the memo comes down twitch you
need to support prime day and everyone's
at twitch is like [__] what do we do and
twitch has a user base that is so easily
offended it's like
anything twitch does any policy it
creates it's like hey we're um
increasing you know the safety and for
women it's like why because women can't
defend themselves it's like dude like
we're just trying to help like we're not
trying to offend anybody every step of
the way but you could sort of do no
right
and um so so people were just like dude
what are we going to do how are we going
to promote this like amazon prime go buy
[__] stuff like people are going to
think we're just total sellouts like
this is not going to be cool so they're
not going to be go over well
so i don't know who the genius is in
this company but somebody was like
like imagine like a tv show where
they're like god like everybody just
think we're just sell out everything is
just a sellout and if you cue the dream
music like sell out sell out i got it
twitch sells out and they made it yeah
they like turned it on its head and they
went self-aware you know like and it's
always sunny it's like the gang you know
the gang goes to a trump rally or
whatever it's like the uh the event was
come watch how hard twitch will sell out
today and they basically leaned into it
completely instead of trying to do it
and then sort of like set themselves up
to catch a bunch of arrows from fan from
the users who were like god stop trying
to promote prime day this is annoying
this is why it was that's why i didn't
want amazon to buy twitch like i knew it
was gonna sell out to this corporation i
call that the eight-mile strategy have
you seen eight mile
yes exactly like there's this one like
the last scene eminem's like yeah i am
white yeah i am poor yeah this dude this
guy did have sex with my mom yeah this
all happened and then it like he makes
it entertaining and then the other guys
are like
[__] i can't make fun of him
yeah like i can't i can't mock that you
you just took it away from me you know
what i mean i'm powerless here
it's the eight mile strategy and i love
it that's exactly what it is and so yeah
they went full slim shady they basically
what they did was they created a qvc
style set right like the cheesiest
salesiest set and then they invited the
big streamers and it was like they
created this like this neon 80s logo
that was like twitch sells out and then
people would jog onto the stage like
today i'm going to sell you this shitty
blender and they like
and people found it so entertaining and
it was funny and it was self-aware and
they
they just like and it sold like crazy
like it was so successful and i don't
know who this was it was somebody in
like the creative marketing department
um i think i met them at one point but i
was like
hey you don't know this but like that
was the number one thing i respected you
know that we like of all the features we
shipped of all the projects we tried
that was my favorite it was my number
one i thought that was so well done
whoever came up with that you had guts
you had creativity and you like turned a
disadvantage into an advantage which is
like for me
that's the highest form of respect when
i see somebody who can take a
disadvantage and flip it to an advantage
it's like that's you're my person you
are you are everything that's right
about business in my book
i love that i'm going to look that up i
want to see uh i want to say i like i
want to see the content i bet it's
hilarious it's good it was really well
done
we need to come up with a better way to
end the show if we're going to come up
the way to start it
yeah
just sort of hey
you never talked about the basketball
game oh yeah you got to talk about that
do you want to talk about that
uh yeah let's do it i got to be a little
vague about it but yeah let's do it you
guys saw so i sent you guys the guest
list for this thing
um
i guess i should explain what it is so i
went to that conference
i went to a conference
and it was fun it was a lot of fun um
but i don't know about you but i have
this like
feeling before i go to a conference
which is like there's like a 48 hour
period before where i'm like
what are one of the reasons i could not
go to do this yeah one of the reasons i
could get out of this i don't know why
that urge comes over me i think like
just the idea in my head of what a
conference entails is like this stuffy
ballroom
like awkward handshake conversations
with people who like you know nobody
knows each other and it's just like
it's like just like the worst first day
of college all over again every day in
my in my professional life now and so i
was like yeah i just hate that feeling
and i hate conferences but like
there is some magic at conferences that
happens or you know i do like meeting
new people i do like learning new things
um and i do like some of the like little
side events that happen in a conference
that are like not the speaker on the
stage and not the like networking mixer
where i have to like
go bargain but
what are you guys talking about
oh you guys known each other for 10
years
cool well uh i'm uh
i'm shawn i have you guys like podcasts
oh you don't recognize that okay yeah
no i was just asking if you guys knew
where the bathroom was i was just
waiting this whole time to barge in and
ask that i'm gonna go now see ya so dude
by the way the best the best way to
approach that i've learned is just
saying hey i don't know anyone here can
i join your conversation
i've noticed that to be the best it's
the upfront method
um yeah exactly so so
i dislike conferences for that reason
and i was like all right
um and at the same time i'm like
dude i miss doing some stuff that was
really fun that i just don't make a lot
of time for nowadays i was like i miss
just playing basketball just like dude i
used to play three hours a day just pick
up was it was so fun that was like the
best time just me and my friends and
just playing we used to meet a bunch of
cool people doing that and so i was
talking to ben and i was like not
producer ben my business partner ben i
was like
i was like dude what if could we get
like the magic of a conference to
combine with the magic of like just
going playing pickup like is there a way
to do this and he's like yeah i got an
idea and so we came up with this idea
which was
we have a friend who trains some of the
biggest like nba stars
and he's been training them for years
and like these are like you know
all-star hall of fame level level
players
and um he's their personal trainer like
he'll go to their house and work with
them every day in the summer and that
same thing things like that
and uh we've become friendly with him uh
because he's a he's an entrepreneur and
we got to know him that way and kind of
helping each other out with our
businesses
and so we were like yo um
his name's alex basil we're like alex
you know you train
kyrie irving you train trey young you
train carmelo anthony you train these
guys like
dude what if i just got a bunch of
business dorks together who all love
basketball and like would you just train
us like you trained them like a fantasy
camp like can we just pretend for a
weekend like we are
we're those guys and he's like yeah i'm
down like just you know pick a weekend
as long as i'm free like we'll do it and
i was like okay and then i was like once
i had one side of it and i was like all
right so let's what if we just got like
10 12 people who were you need your
anchor though you need your whale and we
needed our whale i was like how do i get
people to come to this like first of all
i don't even know who plays basketball
who doesn't i was like who would i wanna
who's like number one a great hang
number two loves basketball and number
three like successful enough in business
where if i go invite the next person
the pull is that these other people are
coming right that's the key to any great
event is these other people are going to
be there the people are the event that
way i don't have to be like great with
the food and bev and like the
environment like all these logistics i'm
not good at like the people are the
event as long as people are there to
work
and so uh um i won't say who but we
landed one big whale
famous person x
and
then the dominoes world famous world
famous mainstream family type of person
exactly so mainstream famous type person
and then i was like okay cool and i
started to get a couple of friends in
and then i sent you the guest list
because you're coming yeah and producer
ben is coming and or like i told you
guys to come i don't know if you guys
are not coming but you should come it'll
be fun when's the day did you say the
date it's next month or it's in 20 days
so it's 20 days from now um
but you saw that guess dude it's coming
together there's some pretty awesome
people going now and now it's way bigger
than like 10 people like we got 20
people this is like how many people do
you want to be their dad owns this nba
team and this person they just sold
their company for all this money and
then this person they're the ceo of this
publicly traded company it's like i
didn't even know that guy likes to play
you know like there's a whole bunch of
really interesting people i think this
is going to be dope and i think this is
a way better way i think this is a hack
where i don't have to go attend
conferences i get to host you should
invite um
lori uh jet.com
i should invite him yeah i haven't
invited him yet that's a good one if he
plays he don't mean he owns a basketball
team
yeah he's awesome i will invite him um
but yeah what do you think about this
this is awesome it's gonna be the best i
think it's gonna be really fun i think
you should invite even bigger more
famous people than just like internet
dorks like
mark would be cool or uh i don't know
who else uh that's actually the hard
part is to think about who to invite but
yeah it's gonna be awesome i think it's
gonna be really fun i think it's a great
idea i think making yourself the center
of these types of things is is badass
it's a net win there's no downside
are you out of pocket any money
um i don't know i haven't even thought
about cost yet but like yeah like it'll
cost money to do this but it's not gonna
be super crazy and i think everyone
would pitch in everyone will pitch in
just nobody's we're not trying to make a
profit off this thing we're just trying
to like you know cover all the costs and
do make it dope no i think it's a great
idea
and it would be it's gonna look sick on
social like it's work related
let's uh
let's tell uh daddy hubspot to pay for
it
hey fellas
um quick break between between games
here just wanna quickly talk to you guys
about your crm needs
they'll be into it i think they're
trying to just gather around i have a
quick powerpoint that i'd love to just
run you through
i think they yeah
but no make them pay for it
if we can record yeah
oh that's the only only record we only
need to record one or two things
we should record
each day we could probably record two or
three like things we could even have
like two people on at a time so it's not
like dude and we should get couches
and have people playing in the
background
yeah the game is just running in the
background the audio sucks it's just so
much like screaming from basketball the
full scene guys did a uh the full send
guys they had a wedding i think it was
like post malone's manager or some some
like fantasy person was doing a wedding
and they set up a studio off to the side
of the reception area and they were in
there recording a podcast for an hour
and like logan paul popped in for like
10 minutes and this other person popped
in for like five minutes and it was
really cool it was a great pod we should
do something and they're like all right
you guys want to go back like i think
dessert's at our table and they went
back
it was pretty great
yeah it was a really good it was like if
if you explain it to me i was like oh
this isn't cool but i saw them pull it
off and i was like oh this is actually
really neat we should totally do that
and ask hubspot to uh front the bill all
right great all right done done
all right well good idea that's the pod
that was a good one
[Music]
you